Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is an article from the Distill journal,
so expect a lot of intuitive and beautiful
visualizations.
And it is about recurrent neural networks.
These are neural network variants that are
specialized to be able to deal with sequences
of data.
For instance, processing and completing text
is a great example usage of these recurrent
networks.
So, why is that?
Well, if we wish to finish a sentence, we
are not only interested in the latest letter
in this sentence, but several letters before
that, and of course, the order of these letters
is also of utmost importance.
Here you can see with the green rectangles
which previous letters these recurrent neural
networks memorize when reading and completing
our sentences.
LSTM stands for Long Short-Term Memory, and
GRU means Gated Recurrent Unit, both are recurrent
neural networks.
And you see here that the nested LSTM doesn’t
really look back further than the current
word we are processing, while the classic
LSTM almost always memorizes a lengthy history
of previous words.
And now, look, interestingly, with GRU, when
looking at the start of the word “grammar”
here, we barely know anything about this new
word, so, it memorizes the entire previous
word as it may be the most useful information
we have at the time.
And now, as we proceed a few more letters
into this word, it mostly shifts its attention
to a shorter segment, that is, the letters
of this new word we are currently writing.
Luckily, the paper is even more interactive,
meaning that you can also add a piece of text
here and see how the GRU network processes
it.
One of the main arguments of this paper is
that when comparing these networks against
each other in terms of quality, we shouldn’t
only look at the output text they generate.
For instance, it is possible for two models
that work quite differently to have a very
similar accuracy and score on these tests.
The author argues that we should look beyond
these metrics, and look at this kind of connectivity
information as well.
This way, we may find useful pieces of knowledge,
like the fact that GRU is better at utilizing
longer-term contextual understanding.
A really cool finding indeed, and I am sure
this will also be a useful visualization tool
when developing new algorithms and finding
faults in previous ones.
Love it.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!